la tunisie serait telle emphase
d'amorcer ses réformes si
l'assainissement attendu dans la
fonction publique n'est toujours pas
annoncée un porno réforme de la
compagnie aérienne nationale en déficit
depuis plusieurs années vient d'être
présenté le point à tunis avec et notre
correspondant bassin chebbi
750 millions de dinars c'est la coquette
somme que vient de débourser tunisair
pour l'acquisition d'un nouvel airbus
afin de compléter sa flotte
vieillissante et assurer plus de long
courriers c'est ce qu'a annoncé hier son
pdg calais cheli dans le cadre du plan
de relance de la compagnie déficitaire
un plan qui comprend également le
licenciement de 1000 salariés sur trois
ans dans le budget si de restaurer les
normes internationales le transporteur
national a accusé une perte nette de 336
7 millions de dinars en 2020 contre 18,9
millions de dinars en 2019 soit une
augmentation de 1681 5% avec une dette
croissante de 2000 142 milliards en 2020
tunisair coûte cher à un état au bord de
la faillite tout comme le nombre
important de fonctionnaires pointé du
doigt par le fmi qui a demandé des
réformes express sur ce sujet tunisair
ne déroge pas à cette spécificité
typiquement tunisienne avec 7000 agents
pour à peine 20 avions fonctionnel la
compagnie aérienne va à l'encontre des
normes internationales qui fixe un
nombre maximal de 80 à 100 agents pour
chaque avion des difficultés qui ne date
pas d'aujourd'hui accentuée par la crise
du coc vide et l'instabilité politique
qui règne dans le pays alors que le
gouvernement a annoncé un allègement des
restrictions imposées aux voyageurs
entrant sur le territoire national au vu
de la stabilité de la situation
épidémiologique le pays espère renflouer
les caisses de l'état avec une hausse du
tourisme qui pourrait profiter et à la
compagnie aérienne nationale et au
secteur touristique en berne depuis
trois ans